hey y'all it's under catch here in this
tie tuesday video we're gonna be
continuing my series
on dashboarding specifically we're gonna
be comparing
flex dashboard with shiny dashboard
but before i start this video i want to
say that my q a video
is coming up in february so i have a
link in the description
where you can basically submit your
question
you want to ask me for that video i'm
getting a decent amount of responses
uh which is great so i'm looking forward
to doing a q a
um in the future so when i was looking
at
our studio's website um i saw that they
have an example for flex dashboard
and shiny dashboard and i thought that
was kind of interesting because
i was a new shiny developer i would kind
of get confused about
which framework i should be using um i
primarily use shiny dashboard
because i just started out using just
base art shiny
and then i wanted to do more
dashboarding but what's interesting
about flux dashboard is that it actually
uses our markdown
so it's essentially a template for our
markdown
which you can start which then can be
used to create like a dashboard so
i think that's pretty interesting um so
i'm going to basically create
the same dashboard using flex dashboard
and shiny dashboard and see what
are the main differences when you're
actually developing these uh products
okay so for um our shiny
for flex dashboard we're actually gonna
create our markdown document
and then from template you have to click
on flux dashboard
and the template will come um when will
be
available if you install uh flux
dashboard
right so you have to install that
packages flux dashboard
okay so i think what's kind of cool
about oops i'm gonna
do this i think what's kind of cool
about flex dashboard is that it's pretty
user friendly um for
just people starting out because we have
this area that can can be
used as like our um you know our little
sandbox or workspace
area so it's gonna open up the arm
penguins the tidyburst
i'm also gonna include the gigi ridges
package
which is a package that i've been using
uh the past few weeks
which i really enjoy using so i'm gonna
bring in the penguins data set
and then we can just look at what we
want to work with
so we've used this data set beforehand
um and nothing has really happened to it
so
we're gonna stick with this um if we
actually go down
we can see that we have uh you know some
little
headers so we have like a column that's
saying that for this column we're gonna
have a chart a
for this column that's this width we
have chart b and we also have chart c
so let's actually start creating
some charts um i'm trying to decide what
i want to do for this one um let's
actually do a
excuse me actually use the gigi ridges
package
so what i'm going to do is i want to
compare basically
um each species um distribution for
the um continuous variables so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to select
uh minus island and minus sex
i'm going to do a pivot longer
and then i'm going to do a ggplot
uh and we're actually gonna do the
backwards so x equals value y equals
name
and then we do gm density ridges from
the gg ridges package
we also want to do um fill is equal to
species and we can see our first problem
right here
is that these features are on different
scales
luckily what we can do is use the scales
function so we'll just group by name
mutate value is equal to scale
value and then we'll just ungroup that
that way we're basically standardizing
it so we can actually do some
comparisons
well i will say alpha is equal to 0.2
maybe yeah what's your point seven
yeah and then we'll all i will also
include is the
theme legend.position is equal to top
cool so this is gonna be our first chart
and i'm just gonna put it in our chart a
uh
oops later and then what we're also
gonna do is
maybe just do um a simple
box plot so select minus
island minus sex uh pivot
longer my species
group by name mutate
value is equal scale value i know i
could reuse this code but
i figured i could just do it right now
so and then what we'll do is just do a
simple box plot which will be
name y equals value
fill or we'll say color is equal to
species
and call a box plot well
and then in this case i'm actually not
gonna i'm gonna actually yeah i'm still
gonna include it so theme
legend.position is equal to top
cool and that is going to be our other
plot
and finally what i'm going to do is with
our df we're just going to use these
factors
so i'm going to say df count species
island sex
i will drop dnas
and maybe we'll do um
okay yeah maybe what's ggplot actually
maybe i won't even include sex
yeah i'm not gonna include sex because i
don't think i don't think sex can really
be dependent
uh on the species because generally this
to me like relatively
even especially if they're the same you
know penguin they're just a different
species so
i'm not actually gonna include sex i'm
just gonna do island so we can see if
there's any differentiations
um with species and islands which i
think there should be so
um so do island
and fill is equal to species
and a column chart cool and then i'll do
like maybe a position is equal to
dodge right well
maybe maybe we can actually switch that
to
island see how that works
and that instead of position we can just
do hop like that
yeah i actually kind of like this one so
what i'm
also going to do is i'll say uh i want
to convert this to a proportion chart so
i'm going to group by species
and then i'll just say n equals and
divide by some n
for each species so that way we're
getting the proportion
of um islands for each species
all right there you go
and we'll put the budget to the top
you know what we'll we'll even do a
scale why continuous
uh labels is equal to scales
i think we do label percent yes
like that cool and that will be
our other chart i'm going to call this
uh id tuesday flex
i'll say penguin flex
dashboard cool
and now let's just run this i believe
and then we what we can do
i guess is the uh
i'll run this right see if we run all
the chunks below
oh actually yeah i forgot this i have to
do the run time so run time
tiny now what we can do is have this
run documents pop that up
and we have our simple little chart
um i might make it actually a little
smaller than that so i'll do like
500
i think these guys can be by what
400.
okay i guess that's fine uh i kind of
want to change that though
oh well i i think uh with formatting i'm
fine with not really doing a lot of
formatting but let's see if i can
make this a little bit bigger so data
width
um also do labs x equals
y equals
and i'll do labs
y equals
x equals and what else do i want to do
and then again for this one i'll
probably remove the lab so labs
y equals
okay i think that's fine um
so i created this little static document
um but it's not really like an
interactive dashboard it's not like
something
that is really utilizing our shiny
right now this could really just be an r
markdown that's been rendered out to an
html document but
what we what we want to add is
interactiveness
so with adding interactiveness uh what
we need to do is basically
say um column
dot sidebar
and then copy this thing in and now what
we have
is a sidebar and i think this should run
if i just run it
now we have like a sidebar but what we
need to do is actually put a
select input so what we're going to use
is do a
select input
and what i'm going to call this is v
species
the label will be called species
and the choices will be let's say all
adelie um yeah let's i want to make sure
count species
uh
okay so we have that um
that's here what's going on here
so we have all adelie and then chin
strap and gentoo
then we'll do chin strap
and gen2 okay
yep
and then we'll with it select selected
will be
all okay let's run that
okay so now what we want to do is
actually add some interactiveness
oh i just exited out on accident so tell
your tuesday
looks dashboard
okay
i wrote that so with interac with the
interactiveness
um i'm thinking that we should just put
the interactiveness on this chart right
here
so for that we actually have to add in a
render
plot and then put in our ggg our ggplot
object inside this
even though it's still being contained
inside this code chunk
okay so now that we have that what we
can also do is
uh we can do a oops
we can just do a little filter for it so
in this case we'll say
filter um species
is equal to if else
actually we'll say scr detect sar detect
species and the pattern will be if
else uh input
v species is equal to all it'll just be
blank else it'll be input uh
b species so this is a trick where
basically if we select all it'll look
for
no letter and we'll just keep everything
if it isn't all then i'll just select
whatever is in the choice um let's see
if this
actually runs
oops here to text
input filter ester text species
input plug up that these
there you go it's about that wrong okay
okay so right now we have all put you to
addley
phillips to addly orders the chin strap
built to gentoo and we can see how the
distributions are changing
and we can go back okay
and then right there is our dashboard so
i know i was going pretty fast just
because
i knew really what my thoughts were
gonna be
but what's really cool what i think is
really cool about flux dashboard is
it's like its name it's extremely
flexible dashboard that
um if you're coming from like an r
markdown
cheat where you're just doing an eda and
you want to present it to someone
or share it to like a manager it's
pretty easy to convert those results
from our markdown document
to a dashboard using flux dashboard
i will say um what's also really nice
about it is
it comes with these like predefined
little um templates so
we have them next to each other um with
a column a called b and column c
additionally it's pretty organized
because it's contained in all these
chunks
and adding in and doing all the
formatting is pretty easy
because it's already pre-defined for you
so let's actually do this now in um
shiny dashboard so i'm gonna do a new
file
i'm gonna stay right there i'm actually
go back here and i'm gonna go to shiny
dashboard
get started
copy and paste that in i'm also gonna
load in this
so one thing that i really like about
flux dashboard
is that we can also oops i'm gonna do
tidy
tuesday penguin tiny
any is that
it has this nice progression to it so
when you're coming from oops
i'll check that when you're coming from
like
your eda that's in a you know a markdown
document
you want to show a manager it so you you
convert that
um eda into a flex dashboard
the manager loves it so then you want to
create a fully fledged dashboard
it's very easy to integrate flex
dashboard into shiny dashboard
okay so let's actually do that so title
is equal to
uh let's say penguin i need dashboard
and then our input will just be a
i think was a select input
right and then we have all these things
which will just be render plots so
let's say right there i'll say
output and i'll say penguin
bridges render plot penguin ridges
okay and then for this chart
i want that i'll just type outputs
output penguin box
render plot
put that in and finally we'll just do
this which will be um
output penguin column
give it a render plot and paste that in
it and then what we can do is i guess
say uh
with row
would row in this case i'll just say
what penguin
um box um
plot output penguin ridges
and i'll do box
box and then we'll do another plot
output
and then we have a penguin box
and then a penguin
oh let's run that and see if it works
oops what did i do no
[Music]
oh
uh let's see here penguin render penguin
box
oh it's about output wrong
oh did i not
oh and then i forgot my df of penguins
okay we have this and then we can switch
that to adelie
a tin strap and we have a fully
functioning plot
that we basically took from our flex
dashboard
obviously with um shiny dashboard uh we
have a little bit more
control with it because we can move
these boxes we do
module we do modules and stuff like that
but i think uh after
kind of playing with flux dashboard um i
think flux dashboard is a good
dashboard to just always think about
using
um and then when you actually want to do
shiny dashboard um that's when you can
start doing these
you know granular issues um where you
can add more filtering functions you can
you know you can add more like plotly
stuff
um you can really upgrade that dashboard
but if you have to decide between
you know shiny dashboard and flex
dashboard i i would probably recommend
just using flex dashboard first
and then if you see that you know flux
dashboard has some constraints
uh just copy and paste all of your you
know code chunks into
a shiny dashboard and you'll get a
dashboard pretty
quick up and running so i know this
video was pretty quick
but um i think it shows how how
user friendly plugs dashboard is with
shiny dashboard
and how they both are really easy to
integrate with each other and i really
don't see any reason to
you know ignore one framework or another
i think both of them are relatively easy
to learn
and if you know how to use one it's
really easy to learn the other
so with that being said i'll see you
guys next week and tidy on